starting to translate and ryu
is one of those guys leading the way now
getting a good battle here from aaron
hicks
but it is won by ryu a change-up to get
him he told meredith you know i've been
waiting to be on a postseason roster
since 2017 so
he'll do whatever they they need as
hernandez skies one deep to right
going back is frazier and he makes the
play he made a one-handed running catch
just before he hit the wall beautiful
catch by
frazier who has improved leaps and
bounds
as a defensive player vladimir guerrero
jr steps in knocked home three last
night going two for five
and has 100 career rbis
and he swings and lifts a block fly ball
to deep left gardner is going back
it is good
lady hits one out number eight on the
season of the blue jays have the lead
well we've been talking about vladi all
season long as we hope to get him
hot yeah boy is he getting hot at the
right time
a big night last night as we mentioned
so it's a double for biggio with two
down and now here's beau buchet
look down the left field line and it is
a fair ball
biggio in the score and beshetted the
second and it's two to nothing
he shortens up he fouled off a tough
change up up and away he waits back on
his breaking ball and is able to keep it
fair
that's a good pitch that pitch is down
and in but he stays all the way through
the ball and drives it down the
left-hand line and hits right on the
chalk line
two nothing toronto bottom of the fourth
gretchen cleats off
line oh what a play by hershela
he took a double away from grichik what
reaction
you're right michael that's what it is
it's not there's no thinking about this
this is just their reactive play
jio has such good hands so he lost the
back got to base it yankees have a rally
first and second nobody out
and he got him a cutter way inside and
stant went around
that's a big strikeout for ryu first out
of the inning
right center field who wants it it'll be
tay oscar making the catch two down
the runner is going to tag and come to
third void into third with two down
and it's a good one and a weak ground
ball to second
and what a job by ryu the first two men
reach and the yankees do not score
two on with one out and now the batter
will be lourdes gorilla jr one for two
had an infield hit his last time
up boone trying to keep it right here at
two nothing
97 miles an hour fastball strike goriel
down looking
so two down and now it'll be kirk and
what a good test this is for alejandro
kirk
he has struck out in flight out tonight
and he does hit a slider down the left
field line and into the corner
gretchen's going to come in the score
guerrero's rounding third heading home
and is safe at the plate as kirk doubles
home a couple of runs
and the legend continues to grow
how about that alejandro kirk got a
hanging slider and
hammers it down the left field line
gordon was overwhelmed with the walk the
judge will pinch it for the yankee left
fielder
there's a fly ball to center moving over
is hernandez grichik as well it's t
oscar in right field he makes a catch
two down and now the question is will
they let him finish this seventh inning
dj lemay who is one for three tonight
change up popped up shallow right tay
oscar is there
and ryu and the blue jays are through
seven
leading four to nothing here's the 0-1
breaking ball is grounded to short the
long throw by taurus
is in time first of all it was
a great throw by tour as he made the
jump through
secondly voight was spread eagled on the
ground
making the grab it was close that was a
great play by torres the one thing we
said about the yankees you don't want to
walk them
labor torres will be the batter
and a ground ball to the right side
guerrero will force the lead runner
throw to first but not in time
now it's geo urchella one for three with
a double
ball diving stopped by vr gets to his
feet fires
and gets it past guerrero and bass so a
run will score
and stopping at second is taurus so
archela picks up a hit
hicks crosses the plate yankees on the
board they're down by three
so sanchez pinches for higashiyoka
where the base is loaded as sanchez digs
in
he is the go ahead run a 1-2 and a fly
ball
high in the air to deep left center
grichik back
and he makes the catch up against the
wall
sanchez missed a grand slam by just
a few feet still 4-1 blue jays
and they're in out very likely the
eighth seed
in a year where eight teams get in in
each league but right now they don't
care one bit about that
so now with the runner on it'll be aaron
hicks
on the way swinging a miss he got it
delez finishes it off and the blue jays
are headed to the postseason